From hidden Hamilton references to secret
cameos and West Side Story easter eggs, Lin-Manuel
Miranda's In The Heights is filled with sizzling
details that will make you love it even more.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing over 50 amazing things
you missed and fun facts about the musical.
When Kevin Rosario rings Stanford about his
daughter's tuition fees, the cheery music
he hears when he's on hold is a muzak version
of "You'll Be Back", King's George III's break-up
song to the American colonists in Hamilton.
"Hi Mr Rosario?"
"Yes, yes, I'm here."
The tune is more than just a fun easter egg
for Hamilfans though because it actually fits
the moment perfectly as Kevin is trying to
get his daughter back to university after
she's decided to drop out and the song foreshadows
the fact that eventually Nina chooses to go
back to Stanford.
Lin-Manuel Miranda makes a fun appearance
as the piragüero who has an intense rivalry
with an ice cream seller, which is where the
next Hamilton connection comes in as the Mister
Softee truck driver is played by Christopher
Jackson, who starred as George Washington
in Miranda's revolutionary musical.
And before that, Jackson also starred in the
stage version of In The Heights, originating
the role of Benny, who's played by Corey Hawkins
in the film.
Casting Jackson and Miranda as rival street
vendors in the adaptation is an amusing in-joke
about their real-life close friendship and
their many creative collaborations,
from the Heights and Hamilton musicals, to
the improv hip-hop group Freestyle Love Supreme,
and the Disney musical Moana where Jackson
provided the singing voice for her father.
By the way, make sure you stick around till
the very end of the movie's credits as there's
an extra, fun little scene where the piragüero
gets his own back on the rival who outsold
him earlier in the film when Mister Softee's
truck breaks down.
Cue the piragua guy taking full advantage
of the heat and indulging in a bit of surge
pricing now his competition's out of the game.
The spectacular 96,000 song is one of the
highlights of the movie, and as director Jon
M Chu says, it isn't just "an 'I Want' song
for one character, but for the whole neighbourhood".
The song's number has several layers of significance
in the story.
First of all, Miranda says he chose 96,000
as the prize amount because although it'd
be enough to make a person's life a little
easier, it wouldn't be enough to completely
change things.
Miranda also says that for him personally
"the number '96' has a subconscious wealth
line connotation" because, as a child growing
up in New York City, he noticed the difference
between "the price of living on 94th Street
where he went to school, versus 200th Street,
where he lived".
Which resulted in him viewing 96th Street,
the northern border of the Upper West and
East Sides, as a kind of "economic dividing
line", something which is also referenced
in the opening song.
"I've never been north of 96th Street."
And there may even be a reference to 96,000
in Hamilton which was Miranda's next Broadway
show after In The Heights.
In the song "Right Hand Man", the line "32,000
troops in New York Harbor" repeats three times,
and 32,000 times three equals 96,000.
A detail that only those familiar with the
stage version of 96,000 may have noticed is
the lyric change when Benny fantasizes about
what he'd do if he's the lotto winner.
In the movie, Benny says he'll play golf with
Tiger Woods, whereas in the original song,
Benny brags he'd be so rich that he'd have
Donald Trump as his caddy.
In an interview with Variety, Miranda explained
that when he originally wrote In The Heights,
he viewed Trump as "an avatar for the Monopoly
Man, just a famous rich person", but now "time
made a fool of that lyric, so they changed
it."
The movie's version of the song is an incredible
dance extravaganza that was filmed at New
York's Highbridge Pool.
And shooting the sequence was an insanely
difficult feat to pull off, with the cast
and dancers having to perform in freezing
cold water, while thunderstorms kept interrupting
filming.
In fact, the weather was so bad that the sky
and pool had to be colour-corrected in post-production
as, in the film, it's supposed to be one of
the hottest days of the year!
The aerial shots of Vanessa with an ensemble
of synchronised swimmers moving in geometric
patterns channel Busby Berkeley's renowned
choreography from classic musicals like Million
Dollar Mermaid.
However, achieving the perfect overhead shots
proved a lot harder than initially anticipated.
Firstly, drone filming is prohibited in New
York and a crane had to be carefully constructed
to avoid damaging tunnels below the pool.
Then whenever the swimmers around Vanessa
moved, the ripples and splashes caused the
tube she floated on to drift off.
In the end, they decided to film Vanessa separately
and digitally splice her footage in with the
other swimmers.
Even then, Vanessa's pool ring kept moving
around during filming until Jon Chu decided
to wade into the water himself and hold it
steady for the shot.
Another interesting detail is that although
the movie uses lots of bright colour to fit
the story's celebratory feel, for this scene
Vanessa was dressed in a black bikini to help
her stand out in a sea of colour.
There are shades of West Side Story in When
The Sun Goes Down, Benny and Nina's love song
about their soon-to-be long-distance relationship,
which they sing on a fire escape,
reminiscent of Tony and Maria's love duet
Tonight, whose own roots are in the iconic
"balcony scene" from Shakespeare's Romeo And
Juliet.
Interestingly, some of Miranda's own favourite
childhood memories are "walking through his
neighbourhood and looking up at the fire escapes"
And he got his own West Side fire escape moment
in the new movie during the Carnaval song.
And according to Jon Chu, filming that scene
led to an especially touching moment when
the whole cast chanted Miranda's name in gratitude
at what he'd created.
Funnily enough, during location shoots for
In The Heights in 2019, Steven Spielberg was
mere blocks away filming his new take on West
Side Story, and Miranda even snuck over to
say hello!
And actually, Miranda has some history with
West Side Story himself, having directed the
musical at high school, translated some of
Stephen Sondheim's lyrics into Spanish for
the show's Broadway revival in 2009, and Sondheim's
influence is also found in both In The Heights
as well as Hamilton.
Miranda played the lead part of Usnavi when
the show opened Off-Broadway in 2007.
And originally, he was going to reprise that
role for the musical's big-screen adaptation
when the movie rights were picked up by Universal
after the show won Best Musical, among other
awards, at the Tonys in 2008.
But after the screen version fell into development
hell, bouncing around various backers before
Warner Brothers won the rights in a bidding
war ten years later, Miranda felt he was too
old to play the part anymore.
In the opening song, as Usnavi sings about
emigrating from the Dominican Republic, he
looks wistfully at the map of the Caribbean
on the wall of his bodega.
To make this map unique and give it some character,
the movie's production designer Nelson Coates
decorated it with items Usnavi sells in the
store.
There are Pepperidge Farm Goldfish crackers
to represent the fish in the sea, as well
as lids from cans, perhaps a reference to
the tin of condensed milk Abuela Claudia recommends
he use as a milk substitute.
The Dominican Republic itself is made up of
various pieces of coloured tiles in a form
that resembles the country's flag, which ties
in nicely with the opening song's chorus line,
"In the Heights I hang my flag up on display."
And there was a cute moment you might have
missed when Vanessa first walks into the store
and Benny and Sonny are trying to get Usnavi
to work up the courage to ask her out.
Notice the little rose that Benny gives to
Sonny which he later places on the coffee
cup Usnavi is about to give her.
Usnavi isn't having any of it though and tosses
the flower away.
Speaking to The Hollywood Reporter, Miranda
said the movie's production designer recreated
an In The Heights doodle Miranda did when
he was in college and placed it on the piragüero's
cart.
It's only on screen for a second during the
main movie but I managed to spot it right
here in this blink-and-you'll-miss-it moment,
and it gets a smidge more screen time in the
post-credits scene.
In a change from the Broadway production,
Nina's mother doesn't appear in the movie;
however, there's a little easter egg to actress
Priscilla Lopez who played her on stage via
the photo of her next to the TV during Nina's
childhood flashback.
Another nice detail from that scene of Nina
as a child is the rainbow on the top she's
wearing when her father gives her a new computer.
As a symbol of Nina's restored hope for the
future, she also wears a top with a similar
rainbow towards the end of the movie when
she goes to the protest with Sonny and then
explains to her father how she can use her
education at Stanford to help her community
and those who are undocumented.
By the way, Jimmy Smits, who plays Nina's
father in the film, has a previous connection
with In The Heights.
When he first saw the musical Off-Broadway,
he was so blown away that he told Miranda
that "if they needed anything, he was there
for them."
And that offer led to Smits voicing the national
commercial for the musical's move to Broadway.
During Nina's song "Breathe", as she's welcomed
back by the community, one of the original
Broadway ensemble cast members Doreen Montalvo
has a cameo.
She sadly passed away in 2020 and there's
a tribute to her with the mural "Doreen Para
Siempre" in the movie's credits.
Montalvo was the first actress to audition
for the musical.
She's also the voice of the bolero singer
on the scratched record that plays as Usnavi
is planning to leave New York and return to
DR.
Miranda has said that he played the piragüero
as a "love letter to his grandfather".
So, those glasses you see around the piragua
guy's neck actually belonged to Miranda's
abuelo, and he also carried his grandad's
"cowboy novels" with him during filming, and
I noticed him reading one of those books at
the start of his song.
Speaking of grandparents, the character Abuela
Claudia was based on Miranda's real-life grandmother,
and she's played by the same actress who originated
the role on stage, Olga Merediz.
Seth Stewart, who was part of the ensemble
in Hamilton and played Graffiti Pete during
the Off-Broadway and Broadway runs of In The
Heights, pops up in a cameo in the club as
a bartender.
And, of course, we can't forget the movie's
lead Anthony Ramos, who before now was best
known for his double roles of John Laurens
and Hamilton's son.
Miranda's mum and dad also get a cameo during
the song Breathe.
As Nina walks through her block, Luis Miranda
and Dr Luz Towns-Miranda pop up to greet her
return.
"Welcome home."
It feels appropriate that his parents should
appear during one of Nina's songs as Miranda
has said that "Spiritually, he's much closer
to the character of Nina" than Usnavi who
he played on stage.
Miranda's wife, Vanessa Nadal, gets a cameo
too at the end in the water hydrant scene.
Director Jon Chu keeps the family theme going
as well, with his mum Ruth getting a secret
shout-out in the ghost sign for "Ruth's Bridal"
hidden beneath the sign for Daniela's Salon.
And I spotted another Chu family hat-tip on
Vanessa's rental application where the real
estate agency, Willow Amelia & Co, is named
after Chu's daughter, whose name was inspired
by one of his favourite films growing up,
the 1980s fantasy movie Willow.
And there's even more tributes to Chu's family
in the winning lottery numbers.
His wife's birthday is the fifth month of
the year; Chu's daughter was born in July
2016, that's 7-16; and 33 is Chu's favourite
number.
As for number 26, that's the date his second
child was born in 2019.
And Chu decided to name him after the movie,
calling him Jonathan Heights Chu.
A few more cameos in the film include Quiara
Alegría Hudes, who wrote the book for In
The Heights, and Javier Muñoz who's played
both Usnavi and Hamilton on stage.
And, according to the Hollywood Reporter,
Anthony Ramos's mother and sister also have
cameos in the movie too.
And to discover all the things you might have
missed in Hamilton as well as secret characters,
tap here to watch my full musicals playlist.
So, what did you think of In The Heights?
And did you notice any other cool details
in the movie?
Let me know in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, then I really appreciate
a thumbs-up and a share.
Tap left for my next musical video or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!